all right um
welcome everyone to the ddps seminar
today before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
logistics as usual
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk
unless you have questions and if you do
have questions
you're welcome to unmute yourself and
ask those questions
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that
we can address them in q a sessions at
the end
and second today's abps
seminar is open to external
audiences therefore no classified
discussion is allowed of course so
please watch out
and finally the talk today will be
recorded and
uploaded in our youtube channel so
um so please stay tuned for that info
uh okay that's about it now let me
introduce our speaker today
it is um very great honor to host dr
ramit malik who is an assistant
computational scientist at mathematics
and computer science division in argon
national lab
before he joined the argonne he obtained
a phd
in mechanical and aerospace engineering
at
oklahoma state university through work
on the development of
data-driven sub-grid models for the
large ad simulation
of high aspect ratio flows relevant to
geo
physical fluid dynamics he continues to
work on
data-driven physical simulations since
then
his research interests include physics
machine learning algorithms numerical
methods turbulence modeling
model order reduction high performance
computing
okay today uh dr uh demolish i will
present neural architecture search for
surrogate modeling which is a very
interesting topic
so please enjoy and expect a wonderful
talk from
ramit now without further ado let me
pass the button to ramy by asking one
random question
just to set the stage somewhat informal
for both
speakers and audience today's random
question is
what did you want to be
when you were young was it a
computational scientist at argon
national lab
what's your dream job oh
my my dream job was to be a train
driver a locomotive uh driver
so wow but but i i suppose it it
fluctuated
according to you know what age you're
talking about yeah
early early teens maybe i wanted to be a
detective
and then maybe in college i wanted to be
a musician
but you know it's a stochastic process
right so
okay okay all right so yeah thank you
for that
uh wonderful introduction um and thank
you for the invitation to speak over
here um
always very excited to reach out to
colleagues in
different national labs for some reason
i have not been able to collaborate a
lot with people at lawrence livermore
hope that changes
after this and uh yeah and i
i hope you enjoy the talk and uh yeah
feel free to reach out to me feel free
to interrupt me at any time for
any anything that doesn't make sense uh
and or if there's any jargon you don't
understand
uh happy to explain in further detail
any particular concept okay so today i'm
going to be talking about some work that
i've been doing
uh with some some great collaborators
here at argonne
across multiple divisions although i do
belong to
mathematics and computer science with a
joint appointment at the
leadership computing facility but
this work is in no way as i'm sure you
know being national lab employees
limited to only only uh sort of a subset
of all the scientists that work here
all right so today oh sorry i'm going to
be talking about neural architecture
search which is very interesting topic
like uh like young
said so uh the outline for our topic
is uh is here so we're going to be
talking about
uh i'm going to be introducing you to
how we do neural architecture search
firstly i'm going to tell you what
neural architecture search is if you're
not familiar
and then finally and then secondly i
will be looking at using neural
architecture search as a tool
to construct better reduced order models
right and the idea of reduced order
modeling will also be motivated
and and what we are trying to uh to use
it for
right uh because we are a doa facility
with a significant emphasis on
um on science
and and not uh and not say very
canonical problems
we will be choosing a you know a certain
set of off nominal
tasks for doing forecasting so uh
we're going to be looking at forecasting
for geophysical applications
and finally we'll be giving you uh some
updates on recent developments which we
are quite excited about
and how we can uh you know take this
forward for
various other problems okay
all right so the let me let me motivate
you a little with
uh with what uh you know application
uh we are looking at so we're going to
be looking at geophysical surrogate
modeling so
the i'm sure you know all of you
have in some form or the other heard
about surrogate modeling because
that's the talk of town nowadays right
every every
funding call every every paper has
surrogates in
some form or the other if you're talking
about scientific machine learning uh
because you know we're in the digital
age right and so we are not different
over here what we will be trying to do
is we are going to be trying to build
surrogate models
for for applications related to the
weather and climate
so i'm not sure if you're familiar about
the the new ai for earth system
predictability drive that is being
organized through the doa
i forget which officer was it ber i
think it's br
or bs and and
and the idea in that drive is to use
various elements of ai for data
understanding
for surrogate modeling uh for uh
and and so we are going to take uh the
expertise
that a bunch of members in our in our
group have in surrogate modeling for a
multitude of applications fusion
aerospace combustion
and then uh we are going to see how well
we can do
on these pressing problems that climate
and whether
scientists have when it comes to
forecasting right
and so in this talk i'll first take you
through the formulation of our surrogate
and you know
how we how we sort of model the problem
in such a way that
a surrogate can be built and then how we
can
integrate neural architecture search
within that formulation so
to come up with uh accurate circuits
right
okay so uh and the problem that we're
looking at today as you can see from the
figure on the right
is related to temperature forecasting of
the sea surface or
well the global ocean actually right and
the
applications that we'll be targeting
actually depend very much
uh on the lead time of your forecast
right and also on how
temporally resolved your forecast is so
if i were to predict the weather
tomorrow
there'd be a certain set of people who
were who it would benefit who might it
benefit people who want to
know whether they want to you know carry
an umbrella to work for example right
but if i were to predict the weather
eight weeks from now
it would probably benefit people who are
planning uh for example
in the context of the ocean uh fishing
routes right
or if i were to predict the weather a
year away from now that would probably
affect people who are
uh in invested in the agriculture sector
uh making forecasts for ten years again
would go into
climate and public policy so uh so uh
forecasting is a very loaded word and so
the application that we're looking at
has to be seen in the context of
what the window of the forecast is and
we'll get to that in the future okay
all right so uh before we go into neural
architecture search and you know how
we were able to uh set up this target
model
uh i'm sure a lot of people in the
audience certainly
yongsao is very familiar with this so i
call this
the slide that is almost inevitably in
every talk of mine i haven't modified
this in
ages uh but this is a slide that
actually
uh tells you um
or about a tool that has become
instrumental in all sorts of surrogate
models
whether as a benchmark or actually as an
active component for
for many uh studies so this is the slide
called the proper orthogonal
decomposition
you know depending on your background
you might call it principal components
you might call it the kernel and lower
decomposition
and and the idea here is that you want
to
basically look at snapshots of your data
uh which are which are resolved
in time using a certain temporal
resolution
and use that information to construct a
no
to construct a coordinate transformation
where your
data can be compressed linearly right so
we have
slides in you know later on in the talk
where we look at the non-linear aspect
of things
okay so over here let's say you have
snapshots from
from data which you stack together into
a large matrix so what does this large
matrix look like so you would have
the rows of the matrix correspond to the
different
uh degrees of freedom in your snapshot
so if it's data for for example flow
around the flat plate at an inclined
angle of attack
it would be all the points in that
domain that would be the rows and the
columns would be the snapshots of this
of this process and performing something
like a singular value decomposition
of this snapshot matrix would give you
you know your decomposition where the
left singular vectors would actually
form an orthonormal basis for you to
project your snapshots onto right
the interesting thing about this problem
is that the the singular vectors that
you get from the snapshot matrix
are actually uh capturing coherent
structures in your flow field
uh ordered by the amount of energetic
contributions they have or the variance
they have right so
so over here we could choose to project
our flow field so our project our data
matrix onto only a subset of the
singular vectors
and call this a truncated svd or a
truncated pod
and then get a a reconstruction of your
flow field which is
not quite perfect but maybe for your
application
more than enough right what is the
benefit of this
you have actually reduced the
dimensionality of your data set quite
significantly
there are caveats to this depending on
the type of data set that you have and
we will look at that
in a while for now let's just say that
our data set satisfies the cont
satisfy the need uh or you know
satisfies the
the nature of actually obtaining
a decent amount of truncation by
performing this
reduction all right so why do we like
this particular
uh technique for for obtaining a new
basis you might have a question why
don't we use a fourier basis right
and that's a perfectly valid question
and you could get away with using a
fourier basis for many problems
as you can see for example if you have
you know
all applied mathematicians favorite the
1d viscous burgers equation
if you take snapshots of this in time
time is the axis where my
pointer is you can construct basis
functions
that are optimal in the variance of the
data set
that look like this and so the pod
or the basis that you get from pod
actually add
that little bit of interpretability that
you get
uh in the sense of actually capturing
spectral content
in your flow field so like you can see
over here the left plot shows you the
fourier basis and as you go from red to
blue to
red to green to blue you begin capturing
more and more
uh frequencies in your flow field a
similar behavior also happens when you
use the pod basis
but it's just that the frequencies are
captured in in you know in an l to
optimal way
uh construct from the covariance matrix
of your snapshots
okay so now that we have the pure d out
of the way
we we've realized something we've
actually obtained a
low dimensional representation of your
data set
on this basis that optimally spans
our our data matrix right uh our
optimism
spans our dynamics now uh in that space
we have a couple of options to actually
then
emulate our dynamics or or to construct
a circuit for our dynamics right
so one option is that you can project
your
partial differential equations to that
basis and then obtain what is called a
pod gallery and type formulation uh jung
so has worked extensively on
other variants of this where you know
you could use a petrov galerkin type
projection to to obtain another set of
equations which are
uh which are more in the line of
implicit time stepping
uh what we do over here and i'll tell
you why
is to uh to to avoid clerking
projections
uh for for our differential equations
but instead to use
uh deep learning methods uh for example
the use of something like a long
short-term memory
neural network to emulate the dynamics
on the space of you know expand by these
pod components that we decide to retain
so over here a lot of this this math
is is maybe confusing but people who are
uninitiated
uh what we are doing over here is we are
evolving a
which is the representation of our
dynamics on the pod basis
right and what is happening in
comparison to something like a simple
neural network which is just
a linear operations on our state vector
composed with each other
is that we add a a concept
of of information flow in time so if n
is our time index over here instead of
just
evolving n to n plus 1 by looking at the
current
current state so you know markov type
process
you can actually embed operations that
have
a recurrent loop in it so you can think
of this as a neural network that is
connected to itself uh
in a non-linear manner it's not just an
additive connection so over here
we call this concept a state of a
recurrent neural network or a long
shorter memory neural network
where the current solution actually
affects
the solution in the future uh and the
nature of correlation over time is
actually something that is
learned through uh through the data
implicitly okay
and and this this paper is absorbed so i
should move this guy so
this paper is absolutely uh seminal and
you know it was
it has been uh out there for a long
amount of time way before
all this crazy hype about deep learning
uh and and really it's
pretty much the go-to for everyone for
for doing
uh machine learning of time series data
of course more recently there have been
much more uh
uh much more attractive tools that have
built on the lstm but
it's always a good step to start okay
all right so uh now let me start warming
up
uh the you know that part of my talk was
deals with neural architecture search so
i'm not sure how many of you are
familiar with the dpivo project petro
certainly is in the audience
so deeper is a is a is a software that
is developed here at argonne in the
maths and computer science as well as
leadership computing facility
uh divisions and uh and then you know
it's it's been around for about three to
four years
uh deep fiber tries to
address one of the most severe
limitations of using neural networks for
any particular application
for people in the audience who are
graduate students i know i empathize
with you whenever
your advisor asks you to fit a neural
network for a particular problem
i'm sure uh you are uh
you know excited at first but when you
realize how many times you have to train
you have to change your hyper parameters
or your architecture to
to get that extra five percent of
accuracy i know
how much you will feel like tearing your
head out so
one of the motivations of the deep hyper
project is to actually automate
the construction of neural networks and
the optimization of its hyper parameters
right and
in that sense it's a very general tool
it's not just
applicable for say lstms which is what
i'll be talking about today
but it can work with pretty much every
sort of neural architecture that is out
there and so we have
if you look at the number of papers that
have that have been
published using the piper you can see a
wide spread of
applications i'll be talking about
geophysical target modeling but the
original paper worked up our cancer drug
responses so how to predict
how two types of
drugs how combinations of drugs lead to
patient
outcomes which is a apparently a very
very
pressing issue in the pharmaceutical
business
uh it's also been used to optimize
uh neuromorphic architectures and
it's also been used for optimizing
nuclear physics problems again i'm not
i'm not an expert on those
but i do know that there are there are
applications for which deeper has been
used extensively
so in this particular study what we have
done is we've we've actually
uh pushed the limits of b piper which
which is a
of course a paralyzed software because
you know this is the
this is the doe and uh we've
hooked it up to surrogate modeling for
geophysical flows
and uh more interestingly this uh
i'm going to be talking about some
unpublished work where we actually use
the piper
to also quantify the uncertainty of the
architecture that we used
uh uh and you know uncertainty
quantification and deep learning is a
big issue so that's also something that
the piper now has the ability to do
right
all right so this is the the sort of the
overall schematic of this
talk right so and so the question
you know you might have is okay the pod
lstm sounds like a very obvious choice
for a surrogate model why exactly
should we care it's a good question
right so the
the way our surrogate modeling strategy
is different
from from many people out there is that
the data set that we look at or the or
the assumptions that we make when we
start our surrogate modeling strategy
are actually that we do not have any
information about the underlying
governing laws right
so if you're building a surrogate model
where you know that your data set
has been generated by a certain
numerical solver uh
you actually uh are starting off at a
pretty good position because you know
that you know these are the equations if
it's navier stokes or if it's
compressible
uh navier stokes or or maybe it's the
euler equations
uh and so on and so forth and then by
knowing those equations you can actually
um for example
do these galerkin projection and petrol
galcon projection type ideas that i was
talking about
in which case deep learning is maybe not
the best approach
if you have equations you should
definitely leverage them maybe deep
learning should be used as a corrector
approach and there's work that i've done
in that direction as well you can you
can learn closures
for uh galerkin projection type models
using deep learning but that's a
different topic right over here what
we're assuming is
the data is coming from something like a
satellite so the data set which i'll be
introducing in in the next slide is
actually
um something that we assume we have no
idea about when it comes to the
the governing laws right and that puts
us at a pretty severe handicap
right so so that's the first thing the
second thing is
uh for data sets like these and um
you you have to use some sort of data
driven modeling approach
and that is where deep hyper comes in
and then finds these off
nominal architectures for example this
guy over here that you can see
uh with all its bells and whistles to
actually
extract that extra bit of accuracy
compared to say a manual tuning and also
save time in general right okay
but there has to be a cost benefit
analysis and we will be doing that as
well
okay so what data set are we looking at
right so this is an open source data set
that we decided to do some surrogate
modeling of this data set is called the
optimum interpolation c surface data set
and it's available
at the noaa website uh
and the link is down here right so this
is a very
uh nice data data set to start
your reduced order modeling studies with
for geophysical flows because um
it's not super high dimensional in the
sense of it's not
if you if you do visualize a video of
the data so it doesn't look like you're
looking at say
you know uh you know turbulent flow in a
channel or something it doesn't have
extreme scale separation uh so and
because of that reason it's it's a good
sort of flow to start surrogate modeling
with
but also it has some uh some um dynamics
at uh at periodic time scales so you
know the
the seasons of of the planet cause the
temperatures to change it gets warmer in
the summer in the northern hemisphere
and
and vice versa in the southern in the
winter so
uh you you should um
so you do need to capture these periodic
dynamics but we also have these
long-term patterns
that show up that are associated with
some of nominal weather events for
example el nino
or la lina or the madden junior
oscillation
uh which uh in the in the north atlantic
which actually
uh require some predictive power so
and so that is something that we are
really interested in
here at argonne more interestingly this
data set was com
was collected from ship observations and
uh from composites of ship observations
and satellite
imagery uh since uh the
late 80s and
and so it it represents pretty much like
a target application of
surrogate modeling where you know you
really don't have any equations so you
do need to use data
okay all right so this is the fun part
of
of my talk today right so today we're
going to be looking at uh
how you can configure a neural
architecture search or what you need to
do from a
representational perspective before you
can start searching for neural
architectures right
so um now if for example
uh you know i ask someone to search for
an
architecture right how would you do that
assuming you know how to import
tensorflow and import pytorch into your
python scripts you would probably go in
there and change the number of hidden
layers you might change the number of
neurons right you might
try to add skips and remove skips right
now we want to automate this entire
process
right but we also want to bound the
search space
where we can search for combinations of
these of these operations
and one way to do that is actually
represent the neural network as a
directed acyclic graph
right so once you've represented your
neural network
as such the nodes of the graph
actually represent potential operations
for example over here you can think of
adding an identity layer is a particular
operation
adding a layer an identity layer would
mean do nothing basically right
adding a layer with a certain number of
neurons performing a dropout operation
adding a skip connection
uh changing the shape of the tensor as
is passing through that
particular node these are all possible
operations that can be performed at
nodes
and at edges you have connections
for information to flow in your neural
network right you could also
fix some con nodes to be constant so you
could say that oh
at this particular location in my
network i want
my tensor to be um
you know 10 by one and i want a
particular type of activation function
and i'm not going to
i'm not going to vary on that right so
that's possible as well
but variable notes basically increase
the number of choices your search agent
can make
when you're actually uh constructing new
architectures right
okay so so uh so and
if you actually go to our github
repository and look at our tutorials
you'll see that constructing this
particular type of
directed acyclic graph is absolutely
trivial
and that's one of the things that i
really like about the piper
uh is that the way we actually develop
the
uh develop the the representation of the
director basically graph is that it
boils down to
basically a list of numbers a list of
integers or real value numbers
where each element of that list or that
array corresponds to a particular
operation at a particular variable node
so over here
you you would just use our api to
for example define a search space where
for
various stages in that search space you
would choose to add a variable node or
choose to add a skip connection between
nodes
uh and or choose to add a constant node
right and and as a result of that
you within say 10 to 15 lines of python
you can uh generate some insanely
difficult or different sorry not
difficult different architectures
which coming up as a human uh is
something definitely i i don't think
that is easy
so you could for example randomly
initialize all the
operations in your search space and
and the same search space can give you
wildly different numbers of parameters
widely different numbers of skip
connections and as such
you really allow for
varying degrees of you know function
approximation prowess
from the same spot space okay so for
this particular search space as you can
see
we we added multiple variable nodes and
at these variable nodes we said
uh the options at these nodes are lstm
cells
right so we have combinations of lstms
and they would have a certain number of
hidden layer neurons
uh and uh in addition to that we would
also connect
cells arbitrarily uh and the connection
itself was also a variable operation
okay now you might be thinking okay so
we have this really large search space
and we have the ability to generate
architectures uh you know pretty much at
random
how do we leverage this fact and also
the fact that we have a really large
machine on campus to
to to train these architectures or train
these neural networks
right so over here we uh we leverage
you know doe hpc resources to
actually parallelize the evaluation of
neural networks so
let's say i choose 128 nodes on theta or
theta gpu
and i i tell each node
i'm going to give you one architecture
and you can evaluate it and you can tell
me how good it does on a validation
data set okay depending on that
how good it does on the validation data
set metric i can decide to
ignore that metric and just randomly
keep searching for architectures
or i can choose to use that in an
intelligent fashion and construct
better and better architectures right
and so over here that's what we did
right so we we used an
an algorithm called the uh
differential evolution oh sorry this is
called the aging evolution algorithm
differential evolution is something else
sorry
the aging evolution algorithm actually
interprets
the construction or the search for
neural networks as a
genetic algorithm so you remember i told
you that
any neural network in that search space
that we've constructed can be
represented as a
as an area of numbers right now if you
interpret that area to actually be
a genome you open yourself up to the
possibility of using all these
age-old methods of um of
using genetic algorithms for for
optimizing
a particular function so over here what
we want to do is we want to maximize the
validation accuracy or minimize the
validation loss
given that metric what can we do we can
after initializing randomly a bunch of
different architectures and evaluating
their metrics
we could uh find the
the best architectures in in that
population
and actually perform mutations or
crossovers
here this algorithm does not perform
crossover but it only performs mutations
and you can perform mutations to use
evolutionary pressure to keep the best
architectures in our uh
are you know uh sort of our kitty of
uh viable models and get rid of the
uh the models that are not performing so
well okay
does this work uh if you look at the
numbers
it does so over here what we did for
this particular problem was that we
searched for
um a surrogate lstm for that particular
problem that i'm talking about which was
uh which was basically trying to uh
you know forecast the sea surface
temperature i'll give you specifics on
that in a while
uh and and you can see very quickly i
mean
within a few minutes you went up to very
high validation
uh accuracy and then if you ran it for
about an
hour more you were able to get even
better uh
r squares for this particular task uh
the shaded out area that you're seeing
over here is basically multiple studies
that we
performed to make sure that you know
this this result that we're getting is
not a fluke
so it does seem to be that no matter
what your random seed choice
the architecture search does converge on
a pretty high validation r square
now one thing is important when we are
evaluating these neural architectures
we are not training them for um
the till convergence so you can choose
to do that but
as you know we there is a trade-off that
we have to make over here
some architectures can be extremely
big so if you remember this architecture
over here has a 300 000 parameters
to have an architecture that's extremely
big and allow it to
run till convergence you may end up
actually
having significant imbalance in how
architectures are being evaluated
but if you have these results were
performed on
knights landing nodes and not really on
gpus but if you have access to gpus
where this
gap you know the the high throughput
nature of the of the computing actually
helps you out
you can actually perform a complete
training on your
on your training data set until
convergence before you choose your
architecture
okay so since we were only
training our networks for a few number
of epochs we collected the top hundred
and then we post train the top hundred
for uh
the full duration on a separate resource
and we ended up with the best model that
you can see over here
it's definitely off nominal i could not
have come up with this myself
okay all right now you might be
wondering over here all right so is it
worth the cost right if you've done a
lot of
uh you've spent a lot of quarter hours
you've
increased your carbon footprint
dramatically is it worth
the cost to actually use this procedure
to obtain
an lstm well the answer to that as
is many things in life is it depends
over here
what we did was we compared it to a
bunch of
uh linear methods so you know
uh auto aggressive moving average or
vector auto regressive moving average
methods that have traditionally been
used for
time series forecasting as well as some
you know like standard uh
machine learning methods such as you
know tree based methods for forecasting
and of course we handsomely outperformed
them but when you compare it to
an lstm that is naively chosen again
is it impossible for a uh for a
for for someone with a lot of time and
money on their hands to actually
manually tune in lstm to improve on what
we did
perhaps but it probably takes too long
for me to find out
so by by choosing randomly
lstns with different numbers of layers
and different numbers of neurons
you can see we do better than the linear
methods that is expected
but in general both for training and
testing we're getting uh
about 10 percent if not more improvement
in accuracy
uh in comparison to to these guys okay
so if that 10 is worth it you know
this is something that you should be
looking into but if you're okay with
uh you know more broadband error perhaps
not
so how do we do uh uh in in terms of our
application going back to our
application the plots that you see on
this
uh on this uh slide over here
on the left side show training
performance
so what we're doing over here is we're
actually making predictions
on the space of our purity mode so if
you look at the coefficients
of these bases uh you can see that mode
one has a very
uh very nice sinusoidal sort of
component
uh which basically corresponds to the
seasonal fluctuation
uh in the sea surface temperature right
and uh i have to mention something
over here the lstm
as is uh you know common with many deep
learning methods
is not a system of odes so
because it is not a system of 4ds well
it can be framed as a system of ods but
it
doesn't really do any time integration
uh
there is a limitation to a long term
forecasting using such methods so for
example if i were to start off my
forecast at time t equal to zero and
then let it go
over time the non-linear nature of the
forecast and the fact that
it is actually uh you know using
uh the the the the
optimization was performed only on one
step forecasting
uh causes it to diverge over time so
what we have over here are results where
uh the in the the x-axis on this label
is basically weeks and what we are
making predictions of
is eight weeks of input
and then eight weeks of output okay so
the
the lstm is only evaluated
multiple times uh or eight times and not
more than that because otherwise you get
divergence so uh on the left you have
training which which is good as as you'd
expect
on the right you have testing the
results
at least in this frame of reference look
okay of course this is not very
meaningful at this moment
but one thing i would like to highlight
over here is that
when the results that the comparisons
that we'll be making from now on the
slide and the next
are are with some really high fidelity
pd models
uh for example uh over here we we
compare to
the us department of defense forecast
model called high com
hicom is run uh daily or
at least uh the reference that i pulled
it out of said it's around daily maybe
they've moved on to something else now
and it requires 800 code hours per day i
uh
ironically of a cray xc40 machine our
our
[Music]
neural architecture search was also
performed on an xc40
uh but for one day of forecast whereas
what we are making is eight weeks of
forecast in the future
secondly we compare it to the community
earth system model so this is
a massive community
climate modeling effort
that required huge amounts of computing
on yellowstone and nanocar hpc resource
for each of 30 different modeling
members in the ensemble so each model
had a slightly different set of
governing laws
and then they and the result they were
all averaged of course
in in the eyeball norm you know these
pictures look pretty because they're of
the planet
but uh when we actually went ahead and
made comparisons of
uh of uh you know more quantitative
metrics for example
the uh in the eastern pacific where
the el nino effect actually happens
within uh
this particular set of dates
we were able to see that the the pod
lstm that we actually obtained uh
outperformed csm and high com in in just
the raw matrix the root means quite
error
for the cells for the you know the sea
surface temperature
in celsius now
despite the numbers in this table i um
i would definitely like to emphasize
that we do not claim
to bypass the requirement of pd based
models
like csm hycom and whatever application
that must be in your mind at this moment
uh we are what we are trying to do is we
are trying to say that these circuit
modeling strategies are competitive
alternatives for downstream consumption
in things like optimization
or sensitivity analysis or data
simulation
so uh and and this is kind of observable
because if you actually
probe certain locations in your flow
field
you may have certain locations where a
certain modeling strategy outperforms
the other
even though the aggregate metrics
indicate that
uh our results were better right so
uh one thing that you should know about
geophysical applications is that all
models are wrong
okay uh because what you're doing is
you're just trying to
come up with some uh some
uh you know first principles based
uh explanation for the phenomenon that
you're observing but you're not really
observing everything right there's a lot
of hidden
physics that you're missing out because
of just the difference in scales
and so there is an innate need for any
modeling strategy to be corrected
after the forecast is performed and the
correction is usually
you know performed by some sort of data
fusion or model fusion
uh through observations from satellites
and then ships for example
so since your model has this
broadband error anyway and there is an
infrastructure out there which actually
corrects models as they are splitting
out results
surrogate models are very attractive uh
you know
possibility in this domain okay so just
to make sure that you know
what we obtained wasn't uh wasn't a
complete fluke
we took that particular model uh
and froze its architecture right and we
looked at another data set which is
called the nasa damage data set this is
hosted by oakridge on
one of their online archives
it's a really really well resolved data
set so it's available
on a one kilometer square grid so the
previous data set that i was looking at
was a one degree latitude grid so you
know it had a 180 by 360 snapshot this
had a 4000 by 4000 snapshot
and this was resolved daily of course to
fit everything on the gpu was a massive
task so we had to
course and everything uh by by two
orders of magnitude so
by one uh and uh
and then uh and this this is an
opportunity for another conversation
about how deep learning
hardware and deep learning software have
to adapt themselves to deal with
the simulation tasks that you know that
could truly benefit from scientific
machine learning but that's a different
topic
so over here what we did had we what we
did was we took uh
three uh uh years of data for this for
the
surface temperature and we then
predicted for 2018
uh and uh again over here what we did
was we used the same
architecture uh and we did some
retraining with this new data
and using this new architecture and this
is work that is still underway
we were able to perform a similar type
of forecast problem
where we were able to and you can see
the purity coefficients don't look
all that fine anymore as compared to the
previous results
uh they're not that smooth anymore
because this is a much more stochastic
problem the daytime maximum temperature
over
land is is a lot more stochastic so um
and you can see in terms of again like
ensemble metrics
uh what i'm plotting over here is the
weekly average temperature
for uh for this
region in the midwest over here which
actually encompasses
argon and you can see we are we are able
to get
a good agreement in at least the trend
so
this is still work that's underway but
uh promising signs
okay now uh there may be many people in
the audience who
who just like me have made a career on
hating on the pod because of course the
pod has its limitations
and i am i have several papers
that have actually tried to address the
limitations of pod by using
other forms of
compression instead of say the linear
singular value decomposition based
compression so over here you can see
what issues the pod actually faces
even for something as simple as a 1d
viscous burgers equation which is a
transport dominator phenomenon
you'll see that the convergence to the
true solution
when you're using the purity set of
bases is slow because
uh you know the pods
when you have an adjective type of
solution the kolmogorov width of the
problem is high and then
uh you run into all sorts of trouble
so our goal is to
not just get good forecasts
in a particular in a particular set of
coordinates but to also
reduce the dimensionality of the
coordinates more efficiently so we can
get smaller models right
so so this is some work that we have
done recently on actually
addressing this issue so instead of
using a pod based
uh approach and over here i do use a
pure d gallery in type projection
uh we were able to use a convolutional
autoencoder
for a simple shallow water problem which
had noticed patients it was an
advection-dominated problem and a
convolutional autoencoder was able to
perform like a
was able to extract like an embedding on
which
the information of of the high order
data was
was preserved quite nicely in comparison
to say what the purity was able to do so
over here you have a
like a gaussian pulse in your flow field
that's advected
uh over time and it's a classic example
of an advection-dominant problem and you
know peod
has a tough time in reconstructing that
solution but the cae
and the lstm was able to to do a much
better job so you can see that in this
reference over here
i bring that up because uh
the next part of my talk actually deals
with
using neural architecture search to not
just
perform the forecast which we
just talked about using an lstm but also
to find
and you know the optimal embedding of
our dynamics
on a reduced space so before i proceed
you know i want to have some audience
engagement i i want to ask people
if they can spot what is common among
all these images and maybe we can have a
friendly competition
at argonne i was able to get an
answer in about about a minute or so
let's see how lawrence livermore does
what's what's common among all these
images they're all auto encoders they're
all scraped from
images.google.com i just typed auto
encoder in there
right and they're all from various
sources that import all the references
down but
there's something that's common okay
so brenda says bottleneck layer you're
getting close
but there's something it's symmetric
wow that's great so mikhail
dharma you you win the prize yes
symmetry
exactly so this is something that
um that really bothers me i think it's
because
as humans we are uh so
very um
you know we we like symmetry like the
human face is symmetric and so on and so
forth
uh symmetric people are considered more
attractive etc so uh when
so auto encoders whether by design in
in in your applications or on
on paper in your in your schematics are
always designed to be symmetric
and this is something that we wanted to
question we wanted to use neural
architecture search
for these problems and see is cemetery
really the best
approach for our problem and so
uh for uh for the problem that
uh problems that we looked at for for
example
you know the the shallow water equation
that i was just
showing you so so this guy over here for
example we realized that by
losing the restriction of symmetry our
auto encoders were actually able to get
far better performance and of course
over here what you are seeing
is the uh the performance of an
individual auto encoder just being
plotted over here
but you can see symmetric autoencoders
where we just
allow the uh the number of
uh you know the the activations to
change the filter sizes to change
but the size of the image itself to
remain constant
on both sides not the size of the image
but the the nature of the image being
down sampled so you can think of it this
way
if you allow the the the size of
this layer to to be fixed
but uh but change the uh because it's a
convolutional auto encoder but you allow
the number of channels that it has to
to vary uh you actually get a much
better performance by
allowing you know both encoder and
decoder to have
no reflector symmetry and and we see
this
for uh for multiple applications and so
this is something that's very
interesting to us and and something that
we really want to
uh explore more so um
so that's just a little sidebar that i
wanted to to show you guys
um and then something that that really
hammers on the point that you know
frameworks like
neural architecture search can force you
to challenge you know
your own beliefs about what
architectures are best for a particular
task
okay so uh what else can deep hyper do
so
uh some of the things that we are
working on right now are
related to uncertainty quantification
for deep learning as i'm sure
uh you may have heard from talking to
uh skeptics of scientific machine
learning uh
and and they really raise good points
one of the biggest
sources of skepticism for deep learning
is that the
you know it's black box right and and
the black box uh doesn't really tell you
a lot about why a particular prediction
is made
and so there is a significant amount of
research that is underway both in the
computer science and the
applied math community and of course of
course everybody's doing machine
learning now but
a lot of communities to try and quantify
the uncertainty of the neural networks
so you may have come across schematics
like this
uh where uh instead of having uh
point estimates of weights and neurons
in uh
in in your point estimates of weights
and biases in your neural network for
the prediction of a certain task
you assume that they are sampled from
some distributions
that generally converts your problem
into a very very difficult
posterior inference type of
problem to simplify these things what
people generally do is they assume that
they assume what is called the mean
field approximation where each weight
is assumed to be represented by a
gaussian distribution
a unimodal gaussian distribution with a
certain mean and a certain variance so
you just double the number of parameters
in your deep learning framework
and you perform like a maximum
likelihood estimation of those
parameters right but it's costly
another method that you may have come
across is something called monte carlo
dropout
where during the process of training and
inference random
neurons in your neural network are
switched off and switched on
and as a result of that you get a
slightly different
prediction every time for the same
network uh
you can histogram all these predictions
together you can bin them and then get
some sort of uh information about the
posterior right
so this idea is
almost somewhat childish uh you know to
uh to obtain uh you know histograms of
outputs given inputs by perturbing your
model
uh slightly but this paper where this
was published
has now been cited something like twenty
thousand times it's absolutely
ridiculous so that's that's like two
careers of mine right
so and this guy just recently graduated
from his phd
fantastic okay so moving on uh so so
the third approach uh that that has
become really popular recently something
called deep ensembles what deep
ensembles does is uh uh it's
again going back to analogies that my
phd advisor made
uh do the same thing ten times and come
back to me if it's giving the same thing
right so
what deep ensembles does is it'll take
the same network right it'll initialize
the network from slightly different
starting locations by changing the
random seed and it will get predictions
say if you choose an ensemble of size 10
you'll get 10 predictions
and then you can compute estimates for
the mean and
the standard deviation for example for
each uh
by by looking at each member of the
ensemble so
so this uh is available at this
reference over here this was put out by
by people at google and so uh
by looking at all these ideas we thought
of
uh actually integrating a deep ensemble
uncertainty quantification approach
within our neural architecture search
because you'll remember that our neural
architecture search is actually
obtaining many many hundreds of
thousands of architectures
during the process of finding the best
one so if you choose for example
using a greedy selection the top hundred
or the top 200 architectures
uh which have been performing good or
well for you
you could not just
do an ensemble sampling across
architectures
but you could also change the nature of
the architecture at each
uh eat each member of the ensemble
and and this kind of is the schematic
that shows what we are doing
over here we basically have this nested
problem where
where while previous people were just
searching for the best weights and were
not able to perform any uncertainty
quantification
what we are doing is we are kind of
searching for
best topology so different types of
neural architectures
the hyper parameters in each neural
architecture are also being varied
during the process of the search
and finally by constructing an ensemble
where
you have different architectures
different hyper parameters and their
associated weights were able to
construct a very
diverse ensemble uh for our
uq problem so this is the um
the algorithm that we actually use for
our neural search ensemble it's a it's
still a variant of aging evolution but
over here we are actually
also modifying the hyperparameters so
the hyperparameter
is something like the learning rate or
the
or for example the batch size and these
are also encoded as choices into the
string
which was our gene previously just for
the architecture
and in order to actually make this work
to to capture both data and model form
uncertainty
we had to embed the ability to use
tensorflow probability
in d piper so tensorflow probability is
this add-on that google has put out
that sits on top of tensorflow to allow
for
for example you know approximations like
this where you can have
the mean field approximation or it
allows you to have
the choice of a certain type of
likelihood so that you are not just
minimizing a loss function but you're
also optimizing for the output data
distribution
uh and so or that is predicted or
you're you're optimizing for the mean
and variance of
the output as is being predicted by the
by the model and so your likelihood is
kind of not just
uh a mean squared error but it's also
got the variance term in it
okay so with that
this is work that is still underway we
actually
picked up these benchmark regression
problems so now this talk is turning
into a slightly more cs type talk
we picked up a bunch of these regression
problems that are available in
uh in the machine learning literature so
and they are used to actually
uh quantify uncertainty and accuracy uh
of of your framework so
uh so you can see over here uh we
compared it to the probabilistic back
propagation which is just choose
one architecture and these numbers were
lifted straight out of other people's
papers so we haven't fiddled with them
uh the the monte carlo drop out of the
same architecture deep ensembles which
takes the same architecture and just
retrains it many times and then
our neural architecture search method
which also updates the architecture
in parallel and you can see in general
we are able to do a pretty good job of
of of uh
performing both in terms of accuracy and
in terms of the negative log likelihood
which is
a metric for quantifying uncertainty
okay now going back to our problem which
is
uh finding good coordinates for
embedding our dynamics
you can see as you look at scientific
data these uh
these benchmark regression problems
which are all simple
uh say for example you know
ten inputs to one output or eight inputs
to one output type
uh challenges uh you know the results
are much more skewed in our favor over
here so for example the neural
architecture surge based
uh reconstruction of our true flow field
is much closer is is much better than
something
like a deep ensembles and the metrics
reflect the same
uh not just for for the reconstruction
but also for the negative log likelihood
so the neural statistics search
gives us physically sensible uh
contour plots for where there are
regions of high uncertainty this is the
flow field
and so these are the regions of high
uncertainty
whereas the deep ensemble just utterly
fails and providing
it just gives us this entire region to
be uncertain so
so that's good okay so i i will stop
here
uh because uh uh how much time do i have
in so uh uh well zero time technically
okay okay great so that's a great place
to stop so i just like to leave up some
acknowledgements over here and
thank you for your um thank you for your
uh
for listening and uh yeah feel free to
ask questions
well thank you so much for the great
talk i i i mean
indeed i i really loved it um okay so
let's
have a q a session uh okay um
the brenda asked are there any
surprising arts
that nas last can came up with
uh that offered new insights i i
frequently get that question right so
this is something that we're looking
into
one of the insights that we got was yes
symmetry is definitely
not the best approach when it comes to
encoding architectures
but we haven't been able to get insights
that are very
very very fine so in the sense we are
getting high level insights for example
we are seeing that
if you for example
perform many architecture trainings in
parallel in the neural architecture
search
the architectures that you end up with
are
biased by the fact that faster training
gives you a faster reward right
so we end up in comparison to
other um manually constructed baseline
architectures for the same problem
we end up getting more lightweight
architectures so that is something that
we have seen so
so implicitly by because
you know this is an evolutionary process
uh
offspring which which are generated
faster
are are sort of you know through
evolutionary pressure are selected so we
get lesser parameters in our networks
uh compared to baselines but match them
in accuracy so that's a high level
you know inside that we have got another
thing that
we have planned for
sort of future work is to actually um
change the metrics right now the metrics
that we were using for actually
searching our architecture were very
um were very goal oriented so it was
just okay maximize your r square
maximize your accuracy right if it's
classification
uh but you could for example say things
like i want
to not have so many parameters or i want
to have a certain type of
uh you know like for example uh prior
like i i want my output to satisfy a
constraint for example
how will these change the types of
architectures that are we found
so that that's a very interesting area
up for
uh research uh and we will definitely
look into it okay i think i think you
follow up on this right you're asking
are you thinking about adding more
physics based layers into the nas
framework yeah
that's that's exactly what i was talking
about uh we have started some work
recently on embedding say
loss functions into our into our
so pd based loss functions you know the
the pin work that
that dr karnadakis does into our output
layers
uh but for this particular task we
didn't really know what the pd's were so
we couldn't embed any loss function
but uh but yeah there's a bunch of
things that we can definitely look at in
that
uh that thing okay so
i think there was a question from ryan
ryan can you unmute yourself and ask
your question
yeah first off i just want to say that
was a great talk um
very interesting ideas um so so i was
very
interested in the in the in you know you
sort of have
uh this group of different competing
architectures and you want to
decide which one is is the best by some
metric let's say
so so i'm curious uh
do you actually have to evaluate the
neural network for each one of them to
be able to compare them yes
so they're evaluated from the validation
data set
i see so that that could be
computationally
expensive yeah that could be tough could
it yeah
so you just got bolted on that you just
kind of like generate all these
architectures and
and and just try to find which one's the
best
pretty much yeah so what we do is uh
what we try what we try to do is we um
we try to we don't try to for example we
don't try to take the entire data set if
you're dealing with extreme scale data
sets
uh you know you might end up uh
for example um taking a long time to
train as well as test these
architectures
so in that sense you've lost a lot of
the benefits of neural architecture so
what we do is
we we do we can do a couple of things
one one is that we can
we can choose a subset of the data and
perform this entire experiment
right that that makes it computationally
efficient the other thing that we do
and we haven't compared these rigorously
so we don't know which one is better
is we take a random subset of the data
for actually performing the evaluation
so
maybe there are connections over here
with federated and edge learning i don't
know but
the algorithms if this is not edge
learning but uh but there is a there is
a
um there is a root
or an option or flag or something in the
air in the
in the software that lets us you know
randomly
select a subset of the data perform a
validation return that reward instead of
validating on the entire data set
so so i'm curious when you actually do
this how many uh
how many architectures do you do you
create
hundreds thousands millions probably not
millions
so the reason the results that i showed
you over here were for 128 nodes for
three hours and in that time we were
able to generate about
30 000 architectures wow that's
impressive
wow so you actually you you solve those
30 000
uh ml problems and then sort of take
the top 10 for example top 100 top 10
yeah
we don't well solve with an aesthetics
right the asterix is that
if it uh we we train them only for
let's say we don't train them to
convergence all of them we train them
for
say 20 epochs again this is another
option for you to
um to play around with okay so
if for example you bound your search
space to have
very few parameters right you could
train them all to convergence
right so so there's a lot of dimensions
where
you could uh you could end up
not being able to search for so many
architectures uh
or many more potentially so
yeah okay uh
let's move on to the question by
mikhail uh when you do the epistemic uq
how is the objective in the neural
architecture optimization change
how is the objective yes objective
changes from
uh from something like
a mean squared error to a negative log
likelihood
so the negative log likelihood i mean in
basically it's kind of like the mean
squared error itself but what we do now
is
when we have multiple members of an
ensemble we can calculate the mean of
the ensemble
as well as the standard deviation of the
ensample and that goes into like a
like a sort of like a objective function
and that is what we put down in in that
in that table so um
what we have for both epistemic and
aliatoric
uncertainty quantification is that each
member of the ensemble also predicts a
mean and a standard deviation
because you assume that the output is a
gaussian likelihood
and so then you have to use a excuse me
you have to use a formula like
something like this
something like this where the mu and
sigma for each member of the ensemble is
combined to get an
overall ensemble of the overall ensemble
mean and oral ensemble
variants and that is what goes into
computing like the overall
negative log likelihood which you can
compare with other people's work
does that answer your question yeah yeah
definitely yeah thanks yeah i mean so so
the uh
uq always confuses me the epistemic
illiterate people use different
words for different things so yeah
that's always a good thing to clarify
yeah can i ask another question please
go ahead
yeah i was wondering for like um for the
neural architecture shirt phase
you talk about like genetic programming
i was wondering whether you
to try something else like uh
reinforcement learning with uh
oh yes we have so so i just didn't want
to talk about too many things and
confuse people but if you go to our
reference over here
so we actually compared reinforcement
learning for um
searching for architectures and we
compared it to the genetic
programming uh but the reinforcement
learning is good
when you're
when you're for example trying to do a
lot more exploration than exploitation
so
in this particular problem we did not
require to explore a lot in this search
space so the
genetic algorithm you know got the
better result
but d fiber also comes with
reinforcement learning based things it's
just that the scalability of
reinforcement learning is not really
good
uh you you end up having to wait as
batches of
results come in and aggregate you know
the gradients from those batches and uh
so what ends up happening is that as you
go higher and higher like let's say 500
nodes for example
you will end up having very low node
utilization and as you know in the
leadership computing facilities we don't
like that
but uh evolutionary optimization they
have very high node utilization you can
stay up in the
high point nines even at
500 or 1000 nodes but reinforcement
learning we we end up
by you know paying a big price over
there
okay thanks nice
okay any other questions from audience
uh on brenda uh on uq
have fox looked at dl surrogate for
polynomial chaos
okay so i i know about polynomial chaos
so um uh
you maybe i don't understand the
question so you're
thinking about using dl as a surrogate
for polynomial chaos is that the
question
well okay yeah let me clarify so
essentially in your talk
you talked about using lstm as a circuit
for galerkin projection
yes yeah so just kind of curious since
um
you're interested in uq and i know that
you know in the community some folks
use polynomial chaos as you know another
way to
kind of understand uncertainties in a
dynamical system so
um since i haven't worked on you know pc
polynomial ks for a while
and i figured you're probably more um
you know
aware of the field just kind of curious
whether folks are you know also looking
into
deep learning surrogates um in order to
learn these you know specific kind of
projections to better understand
uncertainties
uh short answer yes they have they have
looked at
uh um so i i i believe i interviewed a
candidate once a postdoc candidate who
actually compared
uh like a deep learning surrogate and a
polynomial chaos surrogate for
uh for uq and
i believe his results were in favor of
the former
but i haven't personally looked at it
yet i i i i was under the impression
and i am by no means a pc person i've
never published anything never written
any code on it i've read some papers
that's all
uh is that you have to make some
assumptions about
the nature of your uh of your
data in the sense of what distributions
the inputs are coming from what
distributions the outputs are
coming from and i think
what dl lets you do is it lets you relax
some of them but you pay the
price of you know getting this black box
alien technology
instead of like something that's more
more better understood like pc
so yeah yeah thank you so much
okay any other questions um well besides
ryan ryan wants to
talk to you i can stick around if the
webex is still up yeah
yeah webex will yeah one definitely
indefinitely
all right that's good uh okay so i have
a i mean
i'm really um interested in
you guys uh um putting some efforts of
you know making the uh that algorithm
you developed in deep
hyper um and introduce a another
criteria of sparsifying the
neural neural network like use the
as small number of hidden nodes as
possible
for example that's a good point and that
in principle that
can be arranged for because
we basically would need to
add like a
yeah we with that there are these
methods uh
called flip out type operations
where you can or or even dropout type
operations where you can switch off
neurons
and uh so i think it should be possible
so one way we
sort of implicitly get what you're
asking is we
uh we can add a reward function that
penalizes
uh too much parameters so we we can say
uh my reward is accuracy
right plus the ratio
of number of parameters
or minus the ratio of number parameters
by some baseline number of parameters
yeah
so if i if that grows a lot you know
the the agent will realize hey
i should not be um
by be selecting these types of
architectures because these are getting
heavier and heavier
so that is something that is yeah
trivially implementable
and on top of that i think if you can uh
actually put some heart constraint on
the oscar
uh sure you know some desirable accuracy
sure yeah so so yeah one one interesting
thing about deeper is that it sits
basically on top of tensorflow
so any model you can construct using
tensorflow operations
uh so even if you use like tensorflow
conditional
operations like if else etc uh you can
search around it using d
piper so you can uh it's it's actually
quite uh
easy to you know construct really uh
really crazy types of
combinations of architectures and
sparsity can definitely be in introduced
that way so right right well i'm i'm i'm
super interested in that sparse neural
network
from deep hyper because you know the
non-linear manifold video studio
that we have uh recently developed it's
super relying on that sparse
structure yeah because you can't do
hyper reduction right
exactly yeah production like you know
just a hundred percent you know
depending on the sparsity okay
so so if the deep hyper can you know
give
us such a sparse neural network this is
this is great yeah we should check more
about
yeah awesome awesome okay looking
forward to it
all right um
okay brenda
okay all right um so maybe
we can um you know wrap up the
the seminar i mean okay from like 80
something
audiences to 17 now
but that doesn't mean um you know your
talk was bad
i i really enjoyed your talk and thank
you so much for the
great help let's let's officially wrap
up the
seminar here yeah yeah feel free to
email me everyone
yeah exactly but um as
ryan uh you know wish and also
probably brenda also um you know any
any folks who wants to stay and uh to
chat with ramit further uh
you know you're welcome to do so um
otherwise
um you know thank you so much
again
yeah all right bye bye happy weekend
so should i stay around uh yeah exactly